>>> LISA MARIE PRESSLEY'S CAUSE
OF DEATH HAS BEEN DEFERRED BY
THE CORONER.
SHE DIED LAST WEEK AFTER BEING
HOSPITALIZED FOLLOWING AN
APPARENT CARDIAC ARREST.
DR. SANJAY GUPTA JOINS US THIS
MORNING.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF DETAILS
ON HER SPECIFIC CASE BUT IN
GENERAL WHY MIGHT A CAUSE OF
DEATH BE DEFERRED.
>> WELL, IT'S BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T IS REALLY OBVIOUS CAUSE
OF DEATH ON THE INITIAL PHYSICAL
AUTOPSY, TYPICALLY.
I'LL SHOW YOU WHAT THEY MIGHT BE
BUT PREFACE THEY CAN FIND A
CAUSE BUT IT COULD TAKE A WHILE,
EVEN WEEKS.
THESE ARE THINGS ON AN INITIAL
AUTOPSY, TRAUMA, STROKE,
SIGNIFICANT INFECTIONS, BLOOD
CLOTS, PULMONARY EMBOLISM.
IF YOU SEE THOSE AND THEY'RE
OBVIOUS WITHIN THE INITIAL
PHYSICAL AUTOPSY THEY MAY COME
BACK WITH A CAUSE OF DEATH.
BUT THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
DEFERRED.
IT CAN BE FOR ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT REASONS.
THEY MAY WANT TO EVALUATE MORE
MEDICAL RECORDS GET MORE
HISTORY.
BUT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR OTHER
THINGS, LIKE DRUGS, ALCOHOL
INTOXICATION, OTHER TOXIC
SUBSTANCES PERHAPS, UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS, HEART CONDITIONS,
PREEXISTING HEART CONDITIONS,
THINGS THAT MIGHT REQUIRE TO
LOOK AT THE TISSUE WITH A
MICROSCOPE, CERTAIN LIVER
DISEASES.
AGAIN, THEY TYPICALLY WILL GET
THE RESULTS BUT WITH THE BLOOD
TESTS AND THE TOXICOLOGY TESTS
THOSE CAN SOMETIMES TAKE WEEKS.
>> WE CAN'T SAY WE DON'T KNOW IF
LISA MARIE HAD A HEART ATTACK
HERE.
THOSE ARE DETAILS WE'RE WAITING
ON FROM THE CORONER, FROM HER
FAMILY.
BUT THERE IS REPORTING AND DATA
TO BACK IT UP, SOMETIMES HEART
ATTACK SYMPTOMS ARE ACTUALLY
MISSED IN WOMEN, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
THIS IS A REAL BIG ISSUE.
I THINK A LOT OF TIMES HEART
DISEASE IS THOUGHT OF A MAN'S
DISEASE.
SHOWING YOU NUMBERS QUICKLY.
IF YOU LOOK AT OVERALL
DISEASES -- DEATHS ATTRIBUTED TO
HEART DISEASE THERE'S 382,000 IN
MEN, THIS IS 2020, 314,000 IN
WOMEN.
SO IT'S A LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
FOR MEN AND WOMEN ALIKE.
HEART DISEASE.
KEEP THAT IN MIND.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HEART
DISEASE FOR MEN AND WOMEN.
BUT CHEST PAIN IS STILL ONE OF
THE MOST COMMON SYMPTOMS IN MEN
AND WOMEN, SHORTNESS OF BREATH
BUT YOU CAN GET WHAT CAN BE
CLASSIFIED AS ATYPICAL SYMPTOMS
IN WOMEN, NAUSEA, VOMITING.
YOU WOULDN'T ATTRIBUTE THAT TO
AN UNDERLYING HEART PROBLEM.
BACK PAIN, FOR EXAMPLE, OR
FATIGUE OR JAW PAIN THOSE CAN BE
THE PRECURSORS TO HAVING A MORE
SIGNIFICANT HEART PROBLEM.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE.
WE DON'T KNOW AND HOPEFULLY WILL
FIND OUT IN A FEW WEEKS WHAT
EXACTLY HAPPENED HERE.
BUT FOR MEN AND WOMEN ALIKE,
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AND YOU
HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO UNUSUAL
SYMPTOMS.
>> GOOD ADVICE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON
THAT.